up
again mike has me here with my elbow
locked up so i can't come into him
i need to force my elbow down express
some cochlea on my hand
i'm going to come in next to my just
like i would for a coke united
but for some reason i can't go this way
anymore so it could be some
one of the strengths is coming up behind
me some situation where i can't move
this way
so instead i'm going to cross in front
of mike this way this makes mike a
shield so if there's someone coming from
this direction
i'm now blocking them with mike as i do
this the sunkeel becomes available
i take the sankyo driving him forward
turn to the front
and bring him down again here i have his
elbow or shoulder trap
i come across with a free hand lock up
to my chest and again
one more time to speak
moro terrorism